actually I've been to Trump's house said
I'm on increment with the locking but I
gotta everyone I was born in Russia and
I was born into a Jewish family my
mother was Jewish
my father however was Armenian and he's
Orthodox Christian but I was never
raised with him
I was raised with my mother growing up I
went to yeshiva it's a Hebrew school
it's very well known there's one called
yeshiva basically Sheba for girls and I
used to speak Hebrew I used to read and
write for about three years until I
moved to New York Salaam alaikum guys
how are you doing
we're in Boca Raton Florida and as
promised I'm bringing you some special
guests here in sunny Florida no
exception we have former practicing
Christian mother was a Jew father was
her mother is a Jew father was Christian
you know I'm just gonna let her explain
all this but it's a made an amazing
story here with marina formerly known as
era here on the D show
[Music]
so now my ankle Montelongo together
everyone I was born in Russia and I was
born into a Jewish family my mother was
Jewish
my father however was Armenian and he's
Orthodox Christian but I was never
raised with him
I was raised with my mother growing up I
went to yeshiva it's a Hebrew school
it's very well known there's one called
yeshiva basically Sheba for girls and I
used to speak Hebrew I used to read and
write for about three years until I
moved to New York and then as you know
they say you don't use it you lose it so
I lost it
growing up I was not very religious we
didn't practice Judaism in our house we
even ate pork my family being Russian
communists back in the days in Russia
they didn't really practice any any
religion
sometimes they were even a theist and I
used to hear things like oh you know
when everything is good look there's God
you see thank God and when things
weren't bad it was like Oh where's God
there's no God so growing up I was a bit
confused you know so I didn't practice
any religion at all I used to just say
things like even there's no God and for
the law and I really didn't believe
sometimes that there was a God due to
all of these confused confusing you know
comments that were made in my family
throughout later on I would think to
myself well you know how could 90% of
people 90% of people believe in God or
in a higher being and Here I am the
small percentage not and then I used to
look at my hands and I used to look at
myself and I used to say no someone had
to create me like I didn't just create
myself and even like at the age of 10 11
12 and I said I there has to be a god
but I went on in ignorance just you know
doing however I want and following
nothing when I went to pharmacy school
back in New York in Liu on the last year
we had some students that were Muslim
and there was a boy and I didn't really
know much about Islam except that what
they said on TV you know that Muslims
are terrorists so there was a guy in
school one of my classmates and how Sam
and he told me you know he was I have a
CD and why you should become Muslim and
it's about a Jewish guy who became
Muslim were you open-minded and
interested in listening to that and I
said sure I said why not so then he
brought me a CD and he said you know
what it's not about I can't find the one
with the Jewish guy this is about a
Christian life it was an art bishop at
the age of 14 and he became Muslim so he
gave me these two CDs and I used to
travel from Brooklyn to New Jersey and
are you guys from that area you know
there's a lot of traffic so I used to
listen to these CDs and they totally hit
the spot for me like the things this
brother said in the CDs it was mostly
about you know being Christian which I
never was really interested in but the
things that he mentioned he said things
like you know you know like you should
believe in one God and everything you
know that you do after that you can
slowly improve you know like even pork
or having a boyfriend and a girlfriend
and all the things that you know
non-muslims do that we used to live in
our lifestyle in the society that we
were raised so after about three weeks
to me I would like to describe the way
it felt was as if your mother you know
that safety and that goodness that you
feel from your mother that's security
that's how I felt about Islam that what
this brother was saying about Islam and
I said you know what no one no matter
what lifestyle I live now I have to live
this lifestyle I have to accept this it
was the truth and I heard it and I just
said the Shahada in the car he told me
on the CDs that all you have to do to
cow Moos ylim you know it's a bear
witness that you're Muslim right here
and right now and I did that in the car
and then I'm little I you know ever
since then that was 25 years ago and
ever since then I've been increasing my
knowledge and you know trying my best to
practice Islam comes in line you know
following all the all the things that
you know as best as I can and I have
never been happier
Islam only made me a better person all
my family members loved me they just
don't like the fact that you know I
can't hug them and kiss them like my
cousins I tell them gotta get over that
you hug me and kiss me enough but other
than that you know it's it's something
that it's something that I could never
thank a lot for as my can never ever
ever thank him enough for that now
before you started to implement Islam in
your life before you start to accept
Islam did you go back to the roots of
your mother what she was upon or you
said they weren't really practicing did
you go until did you go to look into
like maybe there's true Thea or
Christianity did you try to experiment
with other religions no I did not
I'm the type of person Allah had given
us a brain and when I hear something
that's 100% correct I accept it now what
made you also start to reflect and think
about like why am I here what's the
purpose of life many people they don't
really reflect about this was there porn
your life did you where there's
something happening in your life that
how'd you start to really reflect like
you maybe you saw some people see people
dying you know old family members they
have it like a tragedy happen and it
kind of humbles them was there anything
unique that you remember that how'd you
start to think about this very important
issue actually just the fact that I
didn't believe in one
and I didn't believe all of these things
was bothering me I just saw something
inside of me that did not feel correct
even though I was expressing it and
saying it and living it and then I just
was you know sleeping in bed and I so
just look at myself and most I remember
looking at my hands and I was like look
it looked like these veins and like all
this blood flow and like it's just like
I was amazed by the fact that I was
feeling one thing you know and saying
and it's pressing on things but it's not
the case someone had created you it
wasn't anything that happened in my life
it was just a normal I think what's
inside of us that God put in us the
innate in us how do you feel now you saw
this you took the Shahada that was 25
years ago to this day did you start to
implement some people okay think like
you said it's it's innately built in
every human being when that truth comes
right there's a lot of manmade religions
they don't make sense but religion from
the crater it's perfect it makes sense
it goes with what we call the fifth rod
right so you got to give it a shot and
that call to worship the Creator not the
creation you can't argue with that it's
simple it makes sense and the evidence
is just overwhelming I mean it's just so
much there someone is sincere and humble
and they look for the truth they'll find
it in Islam
now many people they accept the truth
but now there's some action that needs
to be followed you got to start
establishing the prayer right for Muslim
woman that modest dress coat how was
that did you
some people implement right away that it
takes some time where's there some
struggles with that actually in the
beginning the prayer how the law was not
a struggle I started to read the books
and I started to read the you know the
Fatiha and what I needed to do in order
to do the prayer one of the hardest
things in the beginning for me was not
to eat those
we're heroes that we used to have in New
York but Hum Dil I switch over to Turkey
you know and I helped a lot as far as
the hijab I always knew you had to wear
it but for the first five years of my
life I did not wear it the reason being
is I was embarrassed you know I was
embarrassed of what people thought about
me and then I say years that's why I was
new knew that I had to wear it and it
was felt bad that I was and I always
made dua I asked I made supplication to
allah o allah please don't let me die
without putting on the hijab you know i
just give me the power to do that and i
one day I said to myself you know I have
people coming into my pharmacy that I
counseled all the time they come you
know exposing their body parts naked and
however and they come in front of me and
you know Here I am covered up I said
people need to appreciate that and
mostly I need to appreciate that you
know this is Allah gave us as a
protection and so I said you know enough
being embarrassed you know other people
should be embarrassed to expose
themselves not me to expose myself the
way I am and I just went to work one day
I'll put on the hijab and I came in and
they're like who are you they thought I
was a floater pharmacist and like it's
me didn't I always tell you guys you
should wear hijab because they used to
ask me they used to say well how come
she's wearing it and you don't wear and
I don't want to make you know the Muslim
people look bad just because I'm
committing something that's a sin and it
is a sin and so it's black and white so
I used to tell them you see her I said
she's doing the right thing you see me I
said I'm doing the wrong thing and I had
several people asked me that throughout
my pharmacy days when I
when I still work in New Jersey and so
I'm the lied I put it on and I fought
myself all day and in the morning and it
was terrible the way I wore but I said
you know what that's it I got to do it
and now of course I can never take it
off it's like part of me part of my
identity and that's another thing people
didn't know that I was Muslim so if
you're not dressed properly and you're
not you know obeying what Allah has you
know commanded on you for your own good
then people really know don't know who
you are and I did not want to be
embarrassed a poem I'm very proud and I
Muslim I'm very very proud and very
passionate about my religion tell us how
do you feel sister here being practicing
Islam in Florida this is Trump's not too
far from here isn't it yeah how do you
feel do you feel there's something
there's some heat now on you do you feel
like any backlash how was the climate
here towards Muslims in Florida actually
I've been to Trump's house not too long
ago I worked with someone who is a
member of merrill ago in West Palm Beach
and for several years she's been
inviting me over and over all to come to
have some meetings over there and I went
over there they treated me like royalty
I didn't feel comfortable going over
there but he wasn't there but they took
me the butler's the staff the woman that
works for me and we had a very good time
as far as being intimidated or anything
like that no I'm not come to LA I you
know believe in whatever is gonna happen
to you and your destiny was gonna happen
to you you just have to do your best you
know and you know make a good impression
for people your behavior should be the
best always in front of your outside or
inside of your house and you know you
just have to be a good Muslim and submit
yourself to Allah and then eventually
actually I think all of the bad exposure
there is good coming out
because there's a lot of people there
asked me about them at work a lot of
people ask me about Islam and I am able
to talk about it in my particular
workplace it's not corporate my cousin
owns the place we fight all the time to
Russian but he's a ghost stuff spreading
this propaganda here I'm like I know
what to do they're asking me you know
and here and there we talk about it and
yeah it's a lot of good stuff is coming
out of this you know people are
interested and they want to know and a
lot of times they research to hear the
truth they accept it however they go
about it but there are a lot of people
that are becoming Muslims the number one
growing religion and it will continue to
be so much other for the common man sure
that we hear many times people will
expose they'll say that all the Muslim
woman you know they they got it all
covered up she's oppressed
right what do you say when you hear that
as a Muslim woman who's wearing hijab
practicing Islam well I can tell you
from both ways from not practicing you
know being a non-practicing muslim' I
grew up in New York and Brooklyn
Brighton Beach I used to walk and it
took these bikini on the beach
practically and my whole young life and
to someone who says that you know Muslim
is being pressed because of the way
she's dressed absolutely not I see it
the other way because the expectations
are very high if you're you know and not
Muslim they're very high everyone always
wants to look good expose as much
private parts as they can their husband
walking around you know displaying them
know you are a treasure and the beauty
you know and you should be covered and
that beauty is not for everyone to see
and that's what I tell the people you
know that I work with they're asking me
well you're so covered you must be hot
no I'm not hot I used to be more hot
when I used to be on the beach or on
that boardwalk or outside you're wearing
nothing yes then the Sun hits your skin
and you sweat a lot more here you're
covered you know and you're not that hot
I love it I I do not feel any kind of I
don't miss anything that I have
before you know if I want to go and you
know in a bathing suit or whatever I
have my backyard this fully covered and
I could do that you know there's nothing
I go to the beach I go just like this
it's funny it's no problem it's great I
don't have to worry about people seeing
me seeing my fat seeing my this seems
like that all my imperfections you know
it's not for anyone to see it's only for
your husband and your family just a
couple more questions for the people out
there actually you know it's not being
the most misunderstood way of life but
as you said is the fastest-growing Way
of life in the world and you just clear
one of the many misconceptions of Muslim
women being oppressed you're missing
woman they've gotten here from you and
we usually often tell people go speak to
the Muslim woman right instead of coming
up with these things from the media and
from your own mind and tell us can you
now that you're you found purpose your
living purpose comparing it to when you
didn't have Islam to now how does it
feel yes before Islam there was no
purpose there was no worship there was
no creator there was no maker there was
just you basically worship others on
yourself
it feels great that I know that you know
I have a purpose in this life and then
insha'Allah God willing you know there's
an afterlife for me and afterlife that
no one can imagine you know just
complete bliss and this is what I strive
for before back in the days I just
always felt empty did whatever I wanted
to depressed and just like doing things
wrong to make myself feel better
drinking and you know the whole society
socializing the wrong way going out with
the wrong people a lot of mistakes your
intellect is not there when you don't
have guidance it's just you can't use
what advice do you have sincere genuine
advice for anyone who's tuned in right
there watching the show the watch of the
D show they're hearing your story they
they like the message of that pure
monotheism connecting with the crater
not worshiping the creation you know
doing good deeds having a blueprint for
life
there's apprehensions what's my family
gonna say you now coming from a
background that your mother was Jewish
your father was Christian right people
are all so timid scared that courage
that they need it's not there but they
want to accept and they're going through
many of these apprehensions what advice
do you have for me well the first advice
I have for them is that those people
that make you feel might be you know
intimidating your family mostly that you
love right now so much they're not gonna
be here for you once you die you're
gonna be all by yourself and you're
gonna answer to your maker your Creator
okay what you have done and how you have
lived and on this earth second thing is
if you maintain your once you become
Muslim you are a much better person you
have more patience with your family your
family will see all of good things as
many non many new convert Muslim
families do they even do admit it you
know they just don't like that what they
hear because maybe they're ignorant the
media so on and so forth my best advice
is if you believe in Allah and you
believe that you have one creator one
maker and you should worship Him in the
way that he wants to have worship don't
let anything stop you make the witness
the Shahada you know take your Shahada
and you you worry about everything else
later on but everything will fall into
place
you just have to maintain the respect my
family they don't like the fact that I'm
Muslim okay for several reasons but they
love do they love me they love me so
much
okay I'm tough a little bit with them
you know
look I don't you know tell you what you
have to do I don't tell you about your
religion the churches you go to you have
to respect we don't have to respect each
other and that's what you have to make
your family your friends understand I
had a lot of friends back in the days
that actually now I'm getting back
together in touch with them because in
the beginning I became our new Muslim
and I didn't know how to handle it it's
very important to know how to handle
relationships when you are new Muslim
you know don't be too extreme don't say
this is Haram just learn ask somebody
always ask somebody if you don't know
the best way to handle whether it's any
man my sister or someone that you know
you can trust and give you good advice
sister thank you so much for joining us
here on the D show